Man ist total auf den Moment fokussiert,
man lebt im Hier und Jetzt.
Man ist in faszinierenden Landschaften.
Anja Blacha zieht beim Training in Zürich
alle Blicke auf sich.
Die Reifen sollen einen schweren Schlitten
im Schnee simulieren.
Es ist das optimale Training
für den Extremsport.
Ich würd mich nicht
als totale Sportskanone beschreiben,
aber ich hab ’ne solide Grundfitness,
und das ist das Wichtige bei Expeditionen,
dass man über ’nen langen Zeitraum
’ne gewisse Leistung erbringen kann.
Im Flachland aufgewachsen,
in den Bergen Rekordhalterin:
Erst mit 25 kommt die Bielefelderin
zum Bergsteigen.
Innerhalb von drei Jahren bezwingt sie
die „Seven Summits“,
die jeweils höchsten Gipfel der Kontinente.
Sie ist die jüngste Deutsche,
die den Mount Everest bestiegen hat.
Ich selber musste miterleben,
wie jemand am Everest gestorben ist.
Man überlegt sich aber eben auch:
Wofür lebe ich und welche Risiken bin ich
bereit, in meinem Leben einzugehen?
Und für mich ist es das Risiko wert,
dass ich … dass ich sterben kann.
In diesem Sommer bezwingt sie den
zweithöchsten Gipfel der Welt,
den K2, ohne Sauerstoffgerät. Als erste
deutsche Frau – der nächste Rekord.
Ich mag gerne immer wieder
was Neues entdecken,
erleben und immer ’n Stück weitergehen,
als ich’s bisher gemacht habe, um …
um zu schauen, was ... was ich
noch erleben kann.
Nun bereitet sich Anja Blacha
auf ihr nächstes Abenteuer vor.
Es ist vielleicht das Gewagteste:
allein mit Skiern und Schlitten
60 Tage im ewigen Eis.
Ich werde von der Küste der Antarktis
über 1400 Kilometer bis zum Südpol gehen.
Der Startpunkt ist auf Berkner Island
und geht dann über das Eis
auf die Kontinentalplatte, durch Gebirgszüge
und dann auf das Polarplateau,
bis man hinterher am Südpol selber
angekommen ist, am geografischen.
Ihre Ausrüstung ist
minimalistisch und praktisch.
Da es unterwegs
keine Versorgungspunkte gibt,
muss Anja Blacha alles selbst mitnehmen.
Akribisch hat die 29-Jährige
ihre Verpflegung zusammengestellt.
Das sind insgesamt 66 Kilo.
Und die werde ich alle in Tagesrationen
verpackt auf meinen Schlitten tun.
Ganz viel Gefriergetrocknetes.
Endlos viele Nüsse,
[die] haben superviele Kalorien auf 100
Gramm – entsprechend gut –
und auch ’nen hohen Fettgehalt.
Viele Süßigkeiten. Butterpulver – einfach,
um das Ganze noch fetter zu machen.
Dann habe ich einiges
an Proteinpulver dabei.
Ich werd jeden Tag Sport machen,
und die Muskeln haben praktisch
keine Zeit für die Regeneration.
Also ist es wichtig, dass ich denen
möglichst ’ne gute Versorgung biete.
Noch nie ist eine Frau so weit allein
durch die Antarktis gelaufen.
Ihr einziger Kontakt zur Außenwelt:
zwei Satellitentelefone.
Geprobt hat sie ihren Trip in Grönland.
Es sind mehrere Dinge,
wovor ich Angst habe.
Natürlich, dass ich
in ’ne Gletscherspalte falle.
Das wär ’n fatales Szenario.
Zum anderen habe ich Angst davor, dass
ein kritischer Ausrüstungsgegenstand
mir zerbricht und unnutzbar wird.
Und das Dritte: dass ich mich
einfach überschätzt habe.
Ein letztes Training.
Anja Blacha fühlt sich gut vorbereitet –
auf die wohl größte Herausforderung
ihres Lebens.